hello everyone and welcome to today's
live flight test on bioplex a protein
interaction that were created from
thousands of protein and you know
purifications my name is anton from lab
roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
presented by lab roots the leading
social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by cell
signaling technology cell signaling
technology is a private family owned
company founded by scientists and
dedicated to privatizing the world's
highest quality innovative research and
diagnostic products to accelerate
biological understanding and enable
personalized medicine their employees
operate worldwide from the US
headquarters in Massachusetts in our
office in the Netherlands China and
Japan for more information please visit
www em before we get started here a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers also welcome you can do
this by hitting the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we're trying to get to as many
as we can and will follow up with you if
we don't have time for it today do you
want a better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly please
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the top right or use the Q&A
button when measuring to resolve any
issues this webinar has been approved
for continuing education credits please
click on the cheat button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits after the webcast
now let's get right to today's presenter
we're proud to present dr. Steven Giggy
their community received his PhD from
the University of Utah in the area has
pharmacology and toxicology he performed
a postdoctoral fellowship recruiting
episode at the University of Washington
in 1996 and joined the faculty at
Harvard Medical School in two thousand
and he is truly a professor in the
Department of cell biology dr. demian is
a leading technologist who uses Nassif
between two answer fundamental questions
in both normal and abnormal biology he
specializes in internal tation advances
for global cellular protein measurements
I'll now turn it over to dr. Steven baby
okay thank you for this opportunity to
speak today I'm excited to try out this
new format which I haven't actually
experienced before I'm also grateful to
cell signaling technology for both
inviting and sponsoring me in this
endeavor I hope it will become
abundantly clear through this talk that
protein protein interactions can provide
a powerful window into nearly any
gene-specific biology so here's the
outline from my talk it will be split
into two parts I will first go over the
key concepts for about 15 minutes and
then I'll move on to an example of
collecting a large protein-protein
interaction data set the bioplex data
set that we'll talk about so first we
need a definition of proteomics and so
proteomics is is really the the
systematic here analysis of proteins for
many properties this includes their
expression their activities their
structures their modification state and
for today's lecture for their
interactions and there are five key
concepts that I'd like to go over to
help us understand a little bit more
about what is mass spectrometry based
proteomics so the first concept is is
that we should remember is what exactly
is a mass spectrometer and what exactly
does it measure well I mass spectrometer
is the smallest scale in the world it
can measure them all it can measure the
molecular weights of atoms for example
carbons 12 nitrogens 14 let's take a
case-specific to proteomics though so
let's say we have three peptides and we
want to know the sequence of those three
peptides let's say one of these peptides
is say seven amino acids in one of them
is 10 and the other is 12 amino acids
you know so we have three peptides that
were interested in and for those three
peptides we want to know the sequence of
those three well the mass spectrometer
can help us with that we could infuse
these into a mass spectrometer and the
memphis
requires two principles to work
everything needs to be in the gas phase
and everything needs to be charged it
can't work with neutrals and so this
electrospray ionization process here can
accomplish both of those and the
peptides can then enter the gas phase in
a charge form and then they can be
passed through this this quadrupole mass
analyzer here which can allow for
determining the molecular masses
expressed as mass to charge ratios for
those and those are detected be an
electron multiplier in this case on the
mass spectrometer and so now we could
know if you look at the the bottom here
where there's a mass spectrum on the
x-axis there's a mass to charge ratio m
/ z and this is really where you're
measuring the mass and on the y-axis
there's the abundance of that they're so
this is the signal of the mass
spectrometer is seen but how does
knowing the how does knowing the mass of
this number 12 here at 667 how does that
help me to know that it's Alan and
glycine leucine arginine how can I learn
the sequence based on just the mass well
to do this we need another step another
stage and actually a different mass
spectrometer which is called a tandem
mass spectrometer so this is called
multi-step analysis multi-step analysis
in mass spectrometry so so this this is
a different situation here because we
have a second stage of mass spectrometry
which is used to collect the sequence
information of the peptide so a mass
spectrometer is capable of collecting
msms spectra and this is where the in
the experiment where the this 667 I in
here is measured in the MS scan and then
a fraction of a second later the mass
spectrometer will turn over and try to
collect an m sms spectrum and let me
explain what that is NM SMS spectrum is
where that 667 peptide ion is physically
isolated away from the other peptide
ions and then it is energized and
collided here
with st. inert gas in the dedicated
collision cell here and so it's
fragmented and then here in the third
quadrupole we read out the fragments
that are coming through there and so
this mass spectrom here this m sms
spectrum here it really represents all
of the fragmentation information the
structural information from that 677 i
and and this really can tell us about
the amino acid sequence here because for
example the map difference between these
two peaks here that might be 99 and that
might be availing right so you could you
could start to learn something about the
sequence information there but the real
key issue here is to do an m sms
experiment you want to fragment
everything but only once and so on
average you take ten thousand molecules
but you're not breaking it down into all
of the amino acids you are breaking it
on average only once so you're creating
two pieces and when you measure the
masses of those two pieces you create a
tandem mass spectrum so peptides can be
can be fragmented in at many positions
on the backbone the and we'd like to
push out a pole here too just to see
what you know what you're what you're
thinking about and where you work but
here is it most commonly the amide bond
which is the place on the ribosome where
the these amino acids are put together
that is the weakest bond and that's
where we're normally a peptide will
fragment and under these conditions and
so if you look at a peptide it will have
many places along the backbone where it
could be cleaved and for example
cleavage here cleavage here would
produce two pieces it would create this
piece here which contains the intact c
terminus and this piece here which
contains the intact in terms may have
different masses but if you if you
fragmented it on average at all of these
different positions but on average only
once per molecule you would read out
these many fragments and that would give
you a tandem s spectrum and then you put
it all together it look something like
this where we can see that the de tandem
a spectrum truly has a very rich supply
of sequencing information contained
within it for example cleavage is here
between this
glycine here that produces those two
halves again as i was telling you this
piece here going down would have a mass
of about 1172 and that would be this
peak right right here so you can see it
starts with the glycine here and ends
with an arginine and it has a massive
1172 so you can see as you look at this
you can see all these fragments and how
they represent the sequence information
so to put this together a little bit
more as a third concept it's about
database searching and protein ID and
and the goal here is really to take this
particular attend on mass spectrum to
reassociate it back with a peptide to
find the sequence of that peptide and
then to sign that back to the protein so
we're just moving backwards towards
where we started to do that you would
think that you could just take the
protein here and take this protein here
and then assign it over to the
identified protein by just collecting
the MSM a spectrum of a protein but
typically we don't deal we don't deal
with we don't deal with with proteins
that much at that level this is a whole
nother field which is called top-down
proteomics is dedicated to just this but
for the majority of us peptide sequence
is much easier and it's more mature to
do this we use kind of a circuitous
route where we start the protein and
then we we move to peptides here try to
draw everything we move to peptides here
by digesting it with an enzyme then
through sequencing in the m sms in the
mass spectrometer we identify those
peptides and after identifying those
peptides we put them back together and
associated them back to get to the
protein so there's a circuitous route
that we take as we move to identify a
protein by mass spectrometry so how does
sequencing work we assign the sequence
match to an m sms spectrum is this is
accomplished by several algorithms the
very first was called sea quest and it
is still the one my lab uses today
seaquest takes for example the entire
protein database from yeast and then it
would digest that protein database in
silico so you create hundreds of
thousands of peptides from those 6,000
proteins and then only the peptides that
had the math that would that could
potentially match the peptide that I'm
seeing would be considered and then you
would see quest would compare a
theoretical can of mass spectrum with an
acquired one that I have here and by
correlating the score for this we could
learn and match the peptide back to
what's in the database so this is kind
of how it works it matches it back up
using predicted spectrum and you can
always go back and look at it and see
how you did with that and inspect it and
see see how things look and what you
really notice when you do this is that
there's really two iron series here
meaning we're sequencing this way from
the c terminus and these ions are the
same same thing but they come from the n
terminus so there's two different iron
series lots of information to help us
the sequence of peptide by mass
spectrometry but the final thing maybe
to remember is that we we are trying to
identify a protein here when we digested
the protein we created many peptides so
we would expect to see many of these
more than one peptide identified by our
database search and indeed in this
example there are seven peptides that we
can see here and these seven peptides
all correspond back to the same protein
so this increases confidence in the
correct identification it really nails
down to splice active forms you might
find a peptide that crosses an intron
exon boundary or you might find one
that's specific to a particular exon it
also can provide a measure of abundance
if I identified by seven peptides in
misc under this condition for this
protein and the next time I identified
by 70 under a different condition the
fact that I had 70 peptides matching
would suggest and you could rightly
conclude that there was more protein
in the other condition so you can use it
as a measure as a quantitative measure
as well this number of peptides and
that's called spectral counting but you
see that use quite a bit where the
number of spectra is kind of a measure
of how much the abundance of the
particular protein was in the mixture so
the fourth concept is putting it all
together it's called shotgun sequencing
and shotgun sequencing is where peptides
are loaded as mixtures on to reverse
fate columns with really small diameters
so these columns are called nano scale
here nano scale capillary columns and
they have very small diameters maybe the
width of a human hair 75 microns in
diameter for example but they're filled
with the same material that you would
see really almost in a normal hplc
column of a bigger diameter these are 5
micron glass beads usually and they are
derivative functionalized with say 18
carbons so they're very greasy they
stick to peptides and then as you
increase the organic concentration
that's going across the column the
peptides will begin to a loop based on
their hydrophobic properties and as they
elude the mass spectrometer sees them it
detects first and then it turns over and
collect an m sms spectrum where it
actually tries to sequence those so as
fast as the peptides are alluding the
mass spectrometer is trying to both
detect them and collect the sequence
information on those and it just goes
around in this big cycle doing this in a
single hour you can collect something
like 10,000 tandem mass spectra across
this cross this gradient here and so you
could imagine that you could take
hundreds of proteins and those can be
digested and put those into this into
this system here and you could probably
identify most of those proteins if not
all of those proteins at the same time
in the mass spectrometer so it's pretty
powerful in fact you could take it one
step further and say what if I had a
HeLa cell this has 10,000 expressed
proteins in this cancer cell if I took
lysate from that and i added trypsin i
would create kind of an unholy mess of
peptides maybe a million peptides well
you could try to separate those peptides
on these columns as well and as they
eluded the mass spectrometer would still
be sequencing this
as it could peptides and as long as
peptides don't co Aleut with the same
mass at the same time the mass
spectrometer could still be able to
identify those and you can identify
thousands of proteins that were present
in that mixture at the same time so it's
a very powerful technique so the final
concept that will talk about for today
is this affinity purification mass
spectrometry so this is abbreviated as a
PMS so a PMS here is where you have a
tag protein here's who has a be here
that I'm circling so this is your bait
protein and for your vape protein you
have an antibody now that antibody is
specific for the bait protein but when
when you pull down on that baby protein
using this antibody here you not only
get the bait but you also collect the
proteins that are associated with it
there Cole amino isolated at the same
time now those proteins may be of
interest to you because you want to
identify those and they could be either
separated on the gel or more likely
today you would just digest them
directly and go into the mass
spectrometer with those and be able to
identify those through through the
protein identification technology that I
was just talking about before and so you
can you can get there and then once
you've identified of those proteins you
can form a network there that kind of
highlights what that Bay protein here
shown today here was really potentially
associated with in this in this mixture
so finding purification is is really a
work is really a workhorse for
identifying interaction partners in
proteomics okay so that's the end of the
introduction here and I'd like to move
on now and we'll have a little poll that
might pop up again that just is asking
what type of amino enrichment techniques
you might use in mass spectrometry so
so in the next 20 minutes I'd like to
highlight our recent efforts to create a
network of protein-protein interactions
that accompany compasses essentially
every protein in the human genome so why
would you want to do this what's the
value in in protein-protein interactions
and so this is just an example that
might help you so tagging an unknown
protein in this case we've tagged this
protein here called gasps sl3 catch sl3
is a protein if you look it up of
unknown function there's nothing really
known about it but when we when we pull
down on this protein it came down with
five other proteins and these five
proteins what we noticed was that three
of these these ones i'm highlighting
here three of these proteins we're
actually part of another complex called
the Gator too complex so this Gator too
complex is involved in sensing amino
acids and relaying that information to
mtor pathways so knowing that the Gator
to was pulled down with gas sl3 here we
could implicate gas sl3 potentially in
the processes of Gator two and if you
look at the structure the gene structure
of Gator to which was renamed get to
sell three which is renamed to cast or
one what you see is it contains these
act domains here so there are two act
domains Dulac domains here and these act
domains and bacteria are are known to
buy nucleic acids as well as amino acids
and the closest homolog in it to the
human act one is right here it says it's
this it says it's part a kinase that
binds actually a lysine into this into
this domain so so there's some evidence
that these act domains can already bind
amino acids and so the hypothesis you
generated that there's some amino acid
that's being bound by gas sl3 and that
that is being then relayed to Gator too
and that that ends up working through
that process with mtor it turned out to
be true this is the paper that was
published here where it was figured out
that that cast or actually binds
arginine life
very specifically and then it can sense
the levels of arginine in the cell and
you can get all that hypothesis and
those ideas directly from just you know
some pull down information and so you
know this is kind of one of the major
reasons why you would want to do protein
poets interactions is to kind of
generate these these new hypotheses
another reason you might want to to
generate cochin to identify proteins
interactors can be illustrated in this
slide here which is fairly complicated
but I think I can can highlight that for
you so what I'm showing you here is a is
a pathway from a signaling transduction
pathway where you have a receptor which
is named are here and that receptor is
going to cause L&M here to disassociate
and then L is going to bind to some new
partners and at the end that all this is
going to end up that that s is going to
be as a transcription factor can enter
the nucleus and it's going to cause the
translation of a new protein which is
going to end up in the in the outer
membrane of mitochondria so this entire
pathway here from the receptor to the
new protein this pathway here you might
want to understand that and if you had
an antibody against l here that i've got
right here circled so if you had an
antibody against el you could pull it
down and when you pull down l you can
see the star graph around it these are
all the proteins that you would pull
down with it and if you knew the
function of R or of lysine or I mean FK
or J or some of these other proteins you
can learn a lot about what L is doing
and so that would be very interesting to
you but if you look at the structure of
that star graph where you have el in the
middle and these other interactors
around it that is not does not resemble
what really the pathway really looks
like however if you were to din then do
more reciprocal pull downs where you you
pick M&T and you and N and P and pull
down on all of those and then you would
create a network that looks like this so
by by performing many
immunoprecipitations we end up with
something that now begins to look a
little bit more like the pathway for
example L here is just two hops away
from s which is the transcription factor
and you can even see some of the
regulatory underlying regulatory
pathways that are present there and so
and so this is a very very strong
argument I think for why one might want
to collect an entire map of every human
of every the interactions of every human
protein and so that's what we set out to
do about three years ago the first paper
was published last year and this
includes a network of thousands really
of these apms experiments so take
thousands of human genes express those
proteins pull those down and see what's
interacting with that and see what we
can learn so this was the first paper
from that so so we named it bioplex
bioflex stands for biophysical
interactions from or film based
complexes and let me kind of explain a
little bit more about what that means so
there's a there's a collection of DNA
called the Orpheum 8.1 so this is 13,000
clones so 13,000 DNA sequences so think
of a hundred and thirty 96-well plates
and each one of these has it has you
know 96 genes of DNA sequences on it and
so we wanted to take each one of those
and to express those in a cell and pull
those down and to identify the
interaction partners from those our
short-term goal was to do this for 2500
which is about ten percent of the human
genome and our long term goal was to
take 10,000 of these and to make a map
for that I'll show you our product our
progress so this is the team of people
that have been working on this so
there's more than a dozen people that
were involved here in fact there's
there's a cell culture team here which
really did a massive amount of work in
growing those those cells up there's
about chemistry team there's an
instrument there's an instrumentation
person here Joe Al Paulo who looks a
little bit tired but has been tireless I
guess in these men
spectrometer in these meta-commentary
experiments the informatics in the data
analysis was was performed by these two
people here by ramin rad and by EDD
Helen and Ed really drove putting
together the all the work for the first
for the first publication here lots of
the data that I'm showing you here he
put together and of course wait Harper
was a big part of this as well as he's a
COPI I and the grand along with Matt so
uh who we began this endeavor together
so it took a lot of people to do this
and let me just highlight for you the
process that we go through for a single
gene so that you can understand how
we're going to do this for then
thousands of genes so for a single gene
we take as I'm showing you here there's
just there's this nice red spot right
here and that is say one clone we take
that out and that gene has the structure
that it's a gene and then the c-terminus
of that gene has an H a tag followed by
a flag tag so these are epitopes that
can be used to pull down so every gene
will have an H a and a flag tag at the
end of it we then packaged this DNA into
a virus here and we infect that into 293
cells now in the 293 cells we create a
stable cell line once we have a stable
cell line which is expressing the tag
form of that particular gene we grow up
six plates those six plates then are
harvested and we do an amino
precipitation experiment using an
antibody against the H a tag and then we
precipitate whatever proteins come down
from that we precipitate those we add
trypsin to digest those and then we
analyze those in duplicate on a mass
spectrometer and this is just an example
of that and so this is the process that
we go through for a single gene to
identify the interacting proteins let me
show you what it looks like for for the
the project here so every single month
we take out about six plates shown here
so six place is about 600 Bates 600
clones and those 600 clones during that
month are going to be packaged into DNA
they're going to be made into table cell
lines they're going to be purified yeah
purified by a me no precipitation after
they've been grown out and shot on the
mass spectrometer and so this all goes
through this this particular process now
to do this we're analyzing everything in
duplicates we use a 70-minute runs 40
min ingredients very quick we use a mass
spectrometer called an orbit trap mass
spectrometer then we have three of these
or their quadruple executive QE mass
spectrometers they collect both high
resolution ms and high resolution msms
information and we invert the run order
and use different instruments in order
to avoid any carryover between between
the replicants these these instruments
run 24 hours a day and they're dedicated
to this project so it's a it's a pretty
mass spectrometry heavy project so
here's the first network that we put
together and this included about 2500
different experiments now only 20 to 75
here are shown and that's because about
300 of these did not have an interac tur
so you had to have a single interactor
to make it into here so they just
interact either what themselves or with
or you know or with nothing so so there
were there were twenty two hundred
proteins and the entire network is made
up of 7600 genes in total so this is
what it looks like in and and that's
what we got for the first one and and
the important thing here was that there
was just a ton of new information here
we're only about eighty six percent of
what we identified was not known before
so the real challenge in these types of
experiments is in it in so it is
demonstrated here so if you have a
protein here and let's say this protein
is cdk1 if i pull down on cdk1 it
interacts with the proteins that i'm
showing you here all of these different
proteins that i'll highlight around here
are interactors but what i really see in
the mass spectrometer is this the meth
electrometer is so sensitive that it can
actually see that it can actually see
about five
100 proteins because there's some
background that's in there that's
identified it's only a single step
purification and so the real key is how
do you go from pulling down 500 proteins
some of which are background some of
which are interactors how do we go from
doing that all the way over to
identifying these 16 interactors that
are there and so these can really be
divided in order to do this we kind of
divide the data into three parts we say
that there are you know there are bona
fide error actors here there are
nonspecific background proteins which
makes up about ninety-five percent of
what's there and then there's one other
category which had never been considered
I don't think in printing point
interactions and that is that there are
actually false positives in there and it
may not seem like a big deal because
it's only 1% the false positives so that
means that there's only five out of
these 495 here only about five of these
proteins are wrong but because they're
false positives meaning that they're
actually wrong identifications they can
match to any protein in fact they can
match randomly and when they match to
any protein they may match to a very
rare protein that I've never seen before
and that's dangerous because that would
look like an interactive it was enriched
because it hadn't been seen before so it
was a specific interactor so by modeling
that in our in the way that we identify
these interactors we've been able to
really remove that problem from the data
set where we don't have these random
false positives don't end up in there
and the background can be modeled out
because we have thousands and thousands
of pull downs all with the same antibody
so we know the background really well so
that's kind of how we did it and what
would I'll tell you more about that is
that we had nine different parameters
nine different parameters here so each
one of these parameters could try to
tell the difference between those three
categories and you'll see one of them up
here you you know might be interesting
as the z-score of course is pretty
important so so a z-score would be how
enriched among the 2500 pull downs that
protein that I identified in that one
pull down how enriched was that oh
or all the other pull downs that I had
ever seen and what you can see is that
you know if these other nine parameters
as well are used and we use something
called a naive Bayes classifier which we
trained using all of the other plates
except the one we were using to do the
analysis we take one played out we use
all the other plates all the data from
the other plates as training data and
then we create this classifier which
spits out probabilities of whether
you're an interactive or false positive
or your background and so that's how we
created we moved from here over to here
to get this map so here's the network
again this network again is represented
by almost 2,600 different apms
experiments and it contains almost
twenty-three twenty-four thousand
interactions so what can we learn from
from these maps and if you just look at
them here here here's three examples and
what I'm showing you here is everything
that we got for this base so xrc see to
it pulls down these three proteins one
two three so these reproaches that's all
it pulled down and these are all
involved in the B cdx2 complex so it
makes sense and these are these are
responding to DNA damage and of course
over here you see the CIF for e which is
pulled down the entire complex
everything is known and except one
protein over here pulls down all of
these other step proteins that pulls
down step 12 Sept 11 so you know pretty
amazing pretty amazing coverage on some
of these complexes and the way that it
works so that was just some good
evidence that it really works well so
how do you benchmark how well you're
doing so there there's a gold standard
in the field called the quorum database
so the quorum database is a carefully
Valentin's carefully validated complexes
that are often from low throughput
experiments it is about as close as we
may come to a gold
standard here is one quorum complex
which is called the ARB 23 complex so
this is involved in actin nucleation and
there are seven known members you can
see the two blue mem the two blue the
two highlighted in blue here are the
ones that are rebates and of course they
pull down the other five members as part
of that it so you get the entire complex
is returned here based on just having
these these two baits so in this case we
have a hundred percent coverage across
this quorum complex here are six other
examples I mean I guess five other
examples of quorum complexes and you can
see the blue or Bates again and that we
were able to pull down basically the
entire complex many times except for
this this one down here where we didn't
do as well but overall you do pretty
well for how you pull down these
complexes and if you if you look at it
in general across all of the complexes
what you what you see is that if i draw
the line here what you see is that for
about eighty percent coverage so we
found eight out of ten members of these
complexes more than half of the time so
that's that's a lot and for and we found
a hundred percent of these complexes a
third of the time so you know these
really tremendous coverage on these on
these well-known complexes that were
required at low throughput that are
annotated in this quorum database and
when we don't do well what you notice is
that we often like right here you can
see this this additional the blue ones
are the ones that were Bates and the
Reds are the ones that are interactors
but the purple one here was one that was
done after that so it wasn't done in the
first 2500 but it was done it's a number
3000 or something and you can see that
it begins to add in a little bit more of
what's happening with this complex so we
fully believe that as we go forward all
these complexes are going to be filled
in based on just including more and more
Bates so once you have this large
network really gigantic network what can
you do with it well I guess we all went
to high school so we all understand what
it means to be in a clique right so the
definition of a clique is that
everything interacts with everything
else
and and the first the best example maybe
of a click is something like this where
you have a three-member click so this is
where all three members are interacting
with each other as you can see this is a
three click and there's an algorithm
called click percolation and click
percolation would take that same click
and it would try to add additional
clicks onto the onto the sides of that
one as shown here and by doing that you
can increase that size of that click and
so this is really a way to kind of
cluster or to find communities in a
network and so that's what it's trying
to do trying to find find clusters find
communities within a network and if you
apply this to the bioplex network you
allow it to go through this click
percolation algorithm what we found is
that there was about 350 different
communities so these 7,000 proteins in
this network they can be filtered back
into about 350 for communities now some
of these communities are very large and
contain you know many many proteins but
not many this is what you up here so
this is this is one that had say that
you know splicing proteins or RNA
binding proteins up here with more than
100 members a few of those complexes but
the vast majority have let are down here
and these have less than 10 members and
so you can see that most of these are
just small complexes of proteins that
are interacting all with each other and
that they form communities and what can
that tell you about about this graph so
here for example what you can see is
that I'm highlighting this box right
here so this is panel I as we call it
here and it has six different
communities that I'm highlighting as an
orange community a blue community like
blue community a green purple and if you
look down here you can see it's blown up
with the actual project which
interactions that are shown within it
and what you see is pretty amazing what
you see is that this network
partitioning is done by this per click
percolation that it really reflects the
real organization that's inside to sell
the real architecture for example you
have the regular
tori and the core particle for the
proteasome you have these other proteins
that are associated with the proteasome
there that are nearby and so you can
really get this this kind of
architecture of the structure that can
be pulled out based on these communities
in how they're organized with each other
you're just another example of how that
is if you look here at this number three
which is right here it's blown out over
here and then you can see it over here
so so this has three communities fairly
large communities this largest community
here the purple one here this is a this
this community here is a large
phosphatase community gigantic and
there's also kinetic horn and RNA
polymerase community here so what this
suggests is that there are common
regulatory factors or their common
mechanisms that are involved in
regulating these that probably the
phosphatases is highly involved in
regulating these two other communities
that can be pulled out together pretty
cool one of the other things you can do
with these communities is you can begin
to do kind of gene set enrichment and
just kind of looking at each community
and seeing what's present at higher than
you would expect with what what
different categories are enriched in
there and so if you you know if you look
here right here you can see that that
that there's something called cluster 72
that in cluster 72 there's a protein
right here in the center called c11 orph
74 so c11 or 74 is a protein of unknown
function that nothing is known about but
everything that it interacts with in the
network its whole community they all are
red and that means that they're all part
of intra silly ery transport and and so
you can imply it in that likely this
protein as well its function it's going
to have something to do with with cilia
and so this is what you can do and it's
really pretty astounding actually
because if you look over here to the
collector 11b and cluster 11 a
remarkably what you see is this is a
mediator complex all
but the meteor complexity its
architecture is actually in 222 pieces
that it exists in the two different kind
of groups in the in the nucleus and you
see that perfectly manifested here in
the in kind of self-organized in this in
these clusters and so you can really use
this to help you understand even some
kind of structural information about
what's going on in the cell here's you
know another example that I like here
and let me see if I can highlight it for
you these three right here show up right
here so these three clusters we call in
cluster 6a 6b and 6c so there are three
different colors I don't know if you can
see it or not there's like a purple or
red and a green but each of these
clusters does the same function they are
histone acetyltransferases that means
they take in a settle group they place
it onto a lysine but there's known to be
three separate complexes to do this and
that d3 has a different function but
they are kind of related to each other
in some ways and you can kind of get
that picture from the map here what you
can see is that they segregate
completely based on which of the three
complexes there in as well as some of
the interactions that they have between
each other so that's really it's really
really pretty great so this network also
this enables us to predict do some
predictions and one of the things you
could try to do is to predict the the
subcellular localization so this is what
we've done here and this is the example
that I'm showing you on this slide here
is if you look here in the center you'll
see psma one so this is psma one if i
start on the network on that big
hairball and i look at everything that's
one hop away that's right next to it
it'll be on this circle that i'm going
to draw right here so everything that's
one hop away will be on that circle so
there's maybe 15 proteins that are
directly associated with psma one in the
network two hops away in the network is
everything on this outer ring and so
what I'm showing you here then in the
colors of the balls litter that for
these interactors is whether it's a
cytoplasmic a nuclear or both you know
for these for the prediction on uniprot
you just look it up on uniprot it tells
you what the
localization is and so we can make
predictions based on these for the one
in the middle so for psma one if you
come over here on this matrix you can
see that is predicted to be both cytosol
'ok and nuclear right here so itís all
like and nuclear because they're in fact
every member of the proteasome as you go
down here every members of proteasome is
predicted to be cytoplasmic and nuclear
except right here so this protein called
p SME 1pm dsm-iii PSM III is a nuclear
specific nuclear specific subunit of the
proteasome and it doesn't show it shows
up only as a nuclear protein here so
again you can use this approach then to
predict for thousands and thousands of
proteins we can predict their
localization based on this approach
pretty cool here's another example where
we predict mitochondrial localization
here it is right here mitochondrial
localization for all of these members of
this you know of these complexes as this
is so just another example there one of
the main reasons that we did this was to
try to add function for the first time
two proteins that no one's ever studied
before there are thousands and thousands
of proteins thousands of genes which
there's nothing known about them they're
just basically have a name and many of
them are just called something like c 16
or 82 so they call them see orff's
because they don't have a function
they're just named that way and here i'm
showing you 271 different see ores and
what you can see here is that there's
the first piece of information the red
ball here is showing you that CRF and
it's and its binding to some other
protein for the first time we have some
information about it and what it's doing
and so it's kind of beautiful and it
kind of shows maybe a little bit of
function about many of these proteins
for the first time we can also predict
your localization so for this in this
case what we were able to do here is
show that look like all right here all
of these see orff's really i guess would
be predicted to be plasma membrane so
something that we know something else
about these unknown proteins right
there's some new of mitochondrial ones
here there are some pretty um
there's what I mean one that the
peroxisome here and one of the lysosome
even right so there are new members at
new localizations in in the cell and we
can get that directly from the network
so there's a lot that you can deal with
this network to predict things and you
can even take those see orff's as I'm
showing you here like here's one here in
the middle and you can see that well
let's look at let's look at this one up
here first so this is a catan in complex
here catan and a and and catan and b and
these two were is known to interact with
each other before and they sever
microtubules and it was it was never
known that there was another subunit
here and so this is the this actually
turns out to be a third sub unit that
can be another regulatory subunit for
this complex and so you get that for
these see orff's you can add some
function to those and find out what they
do so finally there's a there's a viewer
that you can download from the website
if you look at the bioplex website
there's a viewer and in that viewer you
can just take like here's have one for
example you can look at that one and
find out what was interacting with it
there's often you know lots more
information there that you can try to
pick out your favorite protein and try
to understand it so in summary really we
showed that most of the complexes are
faithfully depicted and that most of
these interactions that we found had
never been found before so this was
pretty amazing we had eighty-six percent
were new here really thousands and
thousands of new interactions and that
we could subdivide the network into
hundreds of clusters of these
communities and these were united by the
shared function and localization also I
didn't show you this we for time
purposes but you could you can think
about doing this you have the domains on
these proteins as well and you could ask
questions to see if any two domains are
are enriched or are associated more than
you would expect by chance right so we
did that it for thousands of domains now
we can predict that there that they are
associated with each other for some
reason that there's something there's
something to do with each other and so
we've done that domain enough
as well which is something new and we
can also predict up their localization
as I showed you and finally all these
new new ideas about novel proteins this
is really the most exciting thing for me
was to be able to to just see so many
unknown proteins for which we now have
our first hint about what they're doing
and what their function is so I guess
that's the end of this part here before
we take some questions that I would just
like to really thank the two sponsors
for for this project so it's with dual
funded was funded by the National Human
Genome Research Institute which is part
of NIH and it was also funded by Biogen
so we had a pharmaceutical company as
well as government funding to do this
because it really took millions of
dollars to be able to do this and and
our goal is still to finish the entire
human genome as much as we can and on
the website i think there's almost 6,000
or more of these experiments now whereas
the publication that i showed you only
covers 2,500 so there's a lot more data
there to be looked at it also just like
to thank cell signaling technology for
sponsoring this event here and for
helping us out with getting this this
webinar today thank you very much okay
that was a terrific presentation after
you thank you so much for bringing that
information before we get started with
the live Q&A session they'd like to get
some feedback from the audience so if
you could please give us your thoughts
on the pole that's appearing on your
screen right now we'd really appreciate
your capex and as a quick reminder on
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and we'll try to get to as many
questions as we can and it looks like we
have some great questions already the
first question is what are the
ramifications of using just a single
cell line such as hek293t for bioplex
yeah that's
question I mean our goal was to make a
single pass through a human cell line
now we realize that many of the proteins
that we expressed were never meant to be
in a 293 cells so we took olfactory
receptors we took albumin hemoglobin
things like that we express those in the
two nights resale and tried to do their
interactors it was completely unbiased
and so by using a single cell type we
have some advantages that everything was
the same one was unbiased but there's
some disadvantages that there may be the
interactors may not be expressed in that
cell or the other reason so that's
definitely a caveat to this and the hope
would be to go in and do other cell
lines as well as to do other conditions
may be only during mitosis is is some
complex formed and we wouldn't discover
it using this as well so you know I
think using a single cell line is what
kind of a necessary evil here but it
yeah I think it still worked out pretty
well for us this question is from
Christopher at the Providence Cancer
Center and yes what about protein
polymorphisms the software consider
known the wheels and as for protein
coding genes yeah I mean that's a great
question you you certainly can consider
those typically we use what we call a
reference genome and this is like for
mouse it's the b6 black right so it's
not a different type of mouse it's a v6
black mouse so we don't or for humans
it's just the reference genome we don't
really consider the polymorphisms we
could in the past it hasn't made that
big of a difference because you know
there are multiple peptides / protein
and so you you're definitely going to
miss the one that has a polymorphism but
the peptide a polymorphism but you know
you're not going to miss the protein
most likely so the answer is that the
software can if you want to include that
as a database you could but for now we
don't we just use the reference pacino
okay great next we have a question from
Jason at the University of Cambridge to
ask why are you why are you sure not
Paul now more than one protein with the
target of an antibody I'm a reason is
how are you sure yes why why are you
know
I know more than one point I guess how
are you sure that you're not pulling
more than 130 how am I sure that I'm not
pulling down more than one protein as
attorney so that's that's a great
question as well so so in this
particular case what we're using is we
use the same tag for all 2500 so this is
so think of it that we have the gene and
at the end of the gene we have a tag and
that tag it called the H a tag there's
an antibody we have only one antibody
that recognizes that H a tag so every
pull down is done with the same antibody
now that antibody may not may recognize
that tag it may also recognize something
else but overall we know the background
really well for what that anybody
recognized because we use that same
antibody for everything so it's not that
we're using native antibodies here we're
not we're not going in and pulling down
using an antibody that was made
specifically to pull that down we're
using this an antibody against a tag
which is expressed so it's the same
antibody for everything great your next
questions all that long so feel free to
read along with me comes from Michael at
Harvard Medical School who asked since
it seems like you're measuring a static
condition in one condition would you
always expect that you would always be
an agreement with quorum we're in a
quorum try to capture everything across
conditions right so that's a great
that's a great question again to and so
I wouldn't expect to kick to capture
everything one because 293 cells may not
have that complex we may not have the
conditions right as the as the
questioner says there and so I wouldn't
expect it to always agree but we were
kind of surprised by how much it did
agree and of course quorum complexes are
much more of the kind of universal
complexes like like I showed you the ARP
23 complex the APC complex some of these
other complexes the protease on the
ribosome complexes that are very much
well defined great next we have a
question from Maria at seville
University who asks how can I know
theoretically if two proteins interact
in the plasma membrane with a stimulus
so you needed so I guess the question
there is asking if I have it I need to
have the stimulus present in order to
cause that interaction to occur so again
you could you could certainly do the
pole you could tag and do the pull downs
in the presence of that stimulus and it
would it would allow you to go back to
the question here that fell off my
screen here but you could you certainly
could do the pull down in the presence
of the of the stimulus and see if they
interacted now dealing with plasma
membrane proteins that's a very much
another difficult situation there and it
may not work it may be that you don't
have the right detergent to keep the
membrane proteins happy or it may be
that that interaction is not stable
enough without you know the exact
membrane that you need and in that case
you might have to use something like
cross-linking you could move to chemical
cross-linking where you might stabilize
through through covalent cross-linking
those two together and then find them
there's another idea called bio ID which
is where somebody instead of putting an
H a tag on the end of the protein you
could put a book called a Bison's ligase
type thing called beer a and then you
could that would biotin elate the near
the nearest neighbors instead of pulling
them down you would use buy it and pull
them down so so there are ways that you
could look at this and especially that
person wanted to email me I could
provide more information about what I
what I would do in that case that wasn't
a fantastic next we have a question from
the sushi at Johns Hopkins Medical
School who asked have you tried another
cell lines such as neuronal or yourself
um we have done some of this work not
not a lot maybe a hundred or so in a
cell line called an s Y&5 white cell
line which is kind of a thought to be
more of a neuronal type cell line we've
done some ensure cat cells which are you
know obviously derived from immune cells
but we are currently our next phase of
this project is to create a second map
in another cell line and the second
selling that we've chosen is the hct116
cell line so this is a colon cancer cell
line which is you know one of the issues
with 293 cells of course
they have I don't know 80 chromosomes or
something so they're not 100% normal but
in ATT 116 cell is a bit more normal i
would guess it's a diploid cell it's got
46 chromosomes it looks it looks better
so we'll see how the map as we create
the map again a second time in an ATT
116 cell how that compares but I don't
have we don't have plans to do it in a
neuronal cell they don't transfect that
well or in a foreign immune cell yet
great we have lots of great questions
coming in and the next one it comes from
Rizzo who says interactome is
established from each AK 293 would
future interaction studies also include
other cell types that are
tissue-specific for disease specific
such as cancer so that's a great
question and again i said like i said
we're going to be we are making the map
again right now in hct116 which is the
cancer cell lines so that will be will
be interesting we have plans to make it
in several other cell lines maybe in an
IPS cell you know or stem cell so so
that there are plans to do this and of
course environment is important or
conditions are important too so it would
be great to be able to make a map under
different stimulations of the cell as
well not just different cell types
interesting mixture we have a question
from Duke on to ask can we transient
interactions be identified by this
method yeah I mean that's a pretty good
question I would define a week or a
transient interaction or something like
a kinase binding to its substrate where
it might be five micromolar might be the
binding constant there so I don't think
it can detect those kind of those types
of things but I do think it's not really
detecting only strong binders so again I
think the answer the question is it's
kind of in the middle it doesn't detect
week but it doesn't only detect strong
so I think things that are fairly
transient it can detect but no it's not
at the stage where it's detecting like
substrates for a kinase or an enzyme
reaction or something like that where
it's it's a much much weaker binding
that's happening so yeah these would
have to be fairly stable uh
actions you have to survive the washing
great next we have a question from roads
at that and I eid at NH yes could be non
interactor it's be interacting with
carbohydrates lipids yeah that's a great
question so there are 300 proteins that
we put through here that didn't act like
you're interacting with anything and you
know it could be it could be the protein
it could be the proteins job is to you
know if it's an enzyme and doesn't work
with anything else it doesn't have to
interact with anything else there's no
rule that says you know you have to do
that so no I think that's that's great
and and you know some of these proteins
again remember we tag them at the
c-terminus and if they needed their
c-terminus for function that might be
another reason why they wouldn't
interact with whatever they were doing
right because they weren't functional
anymore so there's a couple of reasons
why they might not be there but
certainly with one stated by the the
questioner is right alright cool next we
have a question from online at Mouton
University grass is perking our action
different different from protein
aggregates yeah I mean I think you know
obviously protein aggregates are usually
precipitated there they're much more
difficult to solubilize and approach
interaction is just how things are
normally happening the normal physiology
in the cell you have you know proteins
interacting with each other and working
together to do their normal
physiological processes so protein
aggregates is more of a kind of a more
towards the disease states okay that's a
no question from child hanging at the
u.p class can you give more details
about how to get rid of false positives
right so for the false positives the way
we did that is it's a bit more technical
so it might be hard to understand but
but you you have to model those false
positives it's only 1% but the way we
modeled the false positives was is that
we had done the search and we had the
proteins in the forward direction we
also had the proteins in a reverse
direction when we did that and so it was
pretty obvious to us that that we had a
good training data for things that
we're completely false positive anytime
we detected and it passed all of our
filters anytime a protein that was
completely bogus it was called a reverse
protein ended up in our network right
and so there were like 10 or 20 of these
that made it through those proteins are
false positive by definition because
they're made from fake proteins so we
would use those to train the model and
find this to show how those got into
there is the same way that the other
ones that we don't know which ones that
we don't know about those so again we
use a known amount of bogus information
to help us understand and to be able to
predict what those false positives were
like and what they were doing very
interesting nice you have a question
from Kirk at the UAMS who asks is this
method compatible with TNT labeling to
compare interactions across multiple
conditions yeah it's a great question if
it might be because the problem you have
is that you have different expression
levels of each of these proteins so if I
took ten different baits and I use TMT
which can measure 10 different 10
different interact homes at once the
issue would be that if one of the base
was expressed at 50 times higher level
than any of the others it might be more
difficult to detect your interactors for
that one because for the one that was 50
times less so you could do it if the
baits were all expressed at this it's
similar level say within two to five
fold of each other in the cell I think
it would work otherwise I think you
would rather stick with different
conditions but the same bait would
probably be a better way to use TMT very
interesting and then we have a question
from the Sun at King's College of London
who asks have you cross-checked
interactions with pathways up yeah so we
have you know done that as well it's
always look over different different you
know all the different cake pathways and
all the different websites and different
things we've been overlaying these data
and other people have actually picked up
our networking or related on top of
networks and pathways as well I really
think it's going to be the best networks
of the certainly the most accurate
network that we have to date so so I
definitely think you can use it for
networks and pathways
um okay that was great questions were
great and the answers were excellent I
think we have a lot more question so we
have time for today but if we didn't get
to your question will follow up with an
email and i would like to once again
thank dr. steven da firs presentation to
have any final comments for us no just
thank you so much for for listening and
I hope you'll use the network and we're
great thing thanks fantastic I would
also like to thank our again our speaker
today for its informative presentation
as well as our sponsor cell signal and
technology for making it possible to
bring this presentation to you today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through September 2016 you
receive an email from libraries alerting
you when it's available for on-demand
and posted on lab reeks calm please feel
free to forward this announcement any
colleagues who weren't able to join us
for today's webcast thank you for
allowing in and participating in our
broadcast today and we'll see you next
time